[Music]
we had a personal interaction that i
think we need to clear up
about a year ago i'm walking on the
beach
in the santa barbara area i don't go to
the beach often for obvious reasons uh
i might catch fire but i was strolling
on the beach and you approached me do
you remember this yes i do well do you
want to tell it from yours do you want
me to supply the details you know my
version and then you told me your
version so i was i'm never in santa
barbara and i was with a friend on the
beach and i see you and there's this guy
and he's wearing a big hat and all white
face no beard sunglasses kind of covered
up everywhere so you kind of look like
those those people with the a-a-a-a on
the beach
yeah i i've got to say i'm not an
attractive presence on the beach
i'm sort of i'm dressed up like a
hundred and ten-year-old rose kennedy
you know that's right that's right what
katherine hepburn exactly i'm all
covered up all right and i say to my
girlfriend which says something about me
i think that's my ex-boyfriend
and she says really are you gonna say
something and i said yeah i am so i
called out and i said
jack yeah and uh you turned around and
you know just kind of glanced and it
didn't um didn't register yeah so then i
i walked down the beach a little bit and
i said no i'm pretty sure that's him
and so i turned around and i said jack
and you turned around and you said no
i'm not jack and i said okay still not
recognizing you so i then
said
you know i wonder what that guy's name
is because it looks so much like him and
i said excuse me what's your name yeah
and you said conan and i went nah it's
not my not my back
now here's the thing
rita and i have known each other a
really long time
i'm six nine
i'm the only guy that looks like big
bird on the beach or on television i say
my name's conan and you went nah no it's
true it was like out of context right
and then we figured it out yes then we
figured it out yeah but that was uh yeah
that was sort of ridiculous it was sort
of and i said conan o'brien from
television you went nah